president trump is offering assurances
to those hit by harvey that his
administration will do everything
possible to help with the recovery
effort yesterday he and the first lady
received a briefing in corpus christi
and visited an emergency operations
center in austin but they did stay away
from houston jamie yukas is in corpus
christi with the president's visit jamie
good morning
good morning president trump's message
here in corpus christi was positive and
optimistic and this city is pretty much
back up and running but at his next stop
in austin he talked about other areas of
state impacted by harvey and called that
a long-term operation
president trump and wife melania touched
down in dry and sunny corpus christi and
as his motorcade made its way into town
they saw little if any signs of damage
the storm actually made landfall about
30 miles away
[Applause]
hundreds of mostly pro-trump supporters
gathered outside the firehouse where the
president was briefed on the recovery
effort
[Applause]
and he made a surprise appearance
outside i will tell you this is
historic it's epic what happened
but you know what it happened in texas
and texas can handle anything corpus
christi resident kenneth ham praised the
visit i think it's really cool to show
support
obviously the optics of it are very good
sam cummins one of about a dozen
protesters on site said the president
came to texas for personal gain only
he's using the hurricane as a political
cover and as a photo op to benefit
himself the president repeatedly
complimented the state and local
officials for their coordination on the
recovery effort
and almost congratulated texas governor
greg abbott before stopping himself
we won't say congratulations we don't
want to do that we don't want to
congratulate we'll congratulate each
other when it's all finished fema
administrator brock long implied
congratulations are a ways off
this recovery is going to be frustrating
we're going to be here with you to help
you guide through it it's going to be
net it's going to be tough to navigate
all the programs that come available
but we're here to help
the president will return to the state
of texas on saturday his spokeswoman
says that trip may now also include a
stop in louisiana nora
all right jamie thank you so much